hello guys it's Greg Alba here I'm Kat
Alvarado Kat Alvarado we've done try not
to laugh challenges but the same guy hey
take the one has done it try not to
cringe challenge which can sometimes be
even harder that someone's very
difficult I'm very cringy yeah you are
like your personalities all right let's
uh okay no cringing but we can smile
or laughs okay oh my god Greg you're
gonna give me nightmares oh my god
Oh God my face wanting to do stuff thing
is I'm cringing with my eyes watery okay
[Music]
what's that supposed to be oh it's like
make sure this person's being taken care
of at his home like institution this
just makes me sad it does
a lot of people are saying that my funny
video where I get angry and do a lot of
rage a lot of people are saying that was
a fail but you want to see something
that's not a fail watch me really it
needs therapy
this whole thing is just making me sad
[Music]
with the razor sharp object but let me
just say this I'm not gonna stab you in
the heart what I'm gonna do is grab a
pen stab you in the neck
Fangio lungs then slam a blunt object
into your stomach stomach you crap happy
bleeding now before you die let me just
say this the reason I call myself Snipes
is because I take my time to Brahma I'm
not complicated but I'm like a sniper
I am striking the [ __ ] or the head I'm
straight to Rick I might hide suitcase
that way
it's so why would someone post this to
the Internet
it's very hard not oh yes don't do drugs
y'all oh no there's gonna be bad
Oh perv
[Music]
she's dancing away I'll pull them this
can't be real
[Music]
this can't be real as our elders plan
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
some convention at conventions Antonio
those creatures are teen wolves and as
ends 5 chicag reports they haunt our
high scores
school's out at John Marshall High but
this could be any school and with any
school come - clicks - cheerleaders
nerves Johnson gum but lately we've
tailed another group on campus literally
we're not to be feared it's not evil
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
I want to really create this me never
seems like not even they're just not
participating didn't know that guy he's
like a philosophy PhD over Anna UC Santa
Barbara
[Music]
[Music]
Wow oh my god oh god that was long I did
not actually expect it to be that
challenging I feel like I have this like
specific pain right here
oh my god I really just want to cut into
what I had to they have this face here
there don't cringe it I feel like my
Lauren's that I cringe smiling
I feel like normally when I do want to
cringe externally I don't want the
person to have their feelings hurt and I
usually do the exact face I was doing
the whole time like you just smile a
crazy person
yeah yeah so you don't want them to know
that you think that they're crazy
seriously man I knew early on this is
gonna be a hard woman guy was eating the
food that was grossing me out so much
with the dude when the kid was slapping
his own face I felt so bad for that kid
like who is this guy's not gonna enough
attention or his parents belong here oh
this one I think is when my headache
started coming dudu is a rat battling
but not making any sense about what he
was doing it wasn't even rhyming that
was humiliating to me because you're in
front of a crowd of people we see other
ones you're like you catch on that it
was a rap like that's how bad the rap
the t-wolves the fed they got the girl
on there being like gangs is one
attention you you're doing everything
Kurtis izing is what you're doing pretty
much I want to find someone who
a Teen Wolf as a teen and then be like
real thing that people are doing doing
Teen Wolf that's depressing
you if you are doing that and you're
watching this channel please stop you
over great if you were a Teen Wolf
please comment below I mean do I accept
everyone sure it's just trust me I mean
if you feel like you're part of a
community and whatever that's fine
violated how do you get it oh my god the
girl must've sent once she must have
uploaded it yeah well you know what I
hope he did something to deserve this
humiliation like cheat on her or
something like that
oh so embarrassing so much cringe when
you have to repress an emotion gosh well
edik the one thanks for doing this buddy
thank you made me feel real
uncomfortable yeah subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell cut
out a comedy on Facebook the cat
Alvarado Instagram and Twitter follow
her ASAP right away bye